[Musique]
merci Pascal grunny de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu den membre du groupe les
républicains et auteur du texte dont on
va beaucoup parler qui a été voté cette
nuit qui interdit l'écriture inclusive
mais d'abord l'actualité on l'a vu c'est
ce nouveau 493 qui a été dégainé cette
nuit par ellisabeth born sur le projet
de loi de sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale le texte arrive au Sénat dans 2
semaines deux motions de censure ont
déjà échoué sur ce texte hier euh sur le
fond du texte parmi les mesures
controversées puisque le débat aura lieu
au Sénat il n'aura pas lieu à
l'Assemblée euh le gouvernement
souhaitait augmenter les franchises
médicales c'est ce qui reste à la charge
du patient quand il va chez le médecin
ou quand il achète un médicament
finalement il semble tergiversé sur le
sujet est-ce que vous êtes favorable euh
personnellement parce que on n'a pas
encore eu le le débat chez nous moi je
ne suis pas favorable non à
l'augmentation des franchise en fait ce
qu'on voit c'est que le le gouvernement
est dans une impasse sur sur les
déficits et que donc il cherche à
prendre de l'argent un peu partout et
dans la poche du contribuable les
franchises ça touche tout le monde en
fait donc c'est c'est quand même assez
ennuyeux je pense que il y en a déjà
suffisamment je pense pas que que ça ça
va faire avancer le le sujet et et
vraiment il faut faire attention aussi
aux Français qui subissent aujourd'hui
l'inflation le coût de l'énergie qui est
qui est très compliqué et on commence à
avoir un peu de froid donc il faut y
penser donc moi je suis personnellement
pas favorable mais je vous dis on n' pas
encore eu le débat sur le sujet il y a
un autre sujet qui fait débat sur ce
texte c'est la ponction que vouleit
initialement faire le gouvernement sur
la agir Carco les caisses de retraite du
privé pour équilibrer le régime de
retraite général là aussi il les renonce
en tout cas pour le moment c'est ce que
dit le ministre est-ce que vous êtes
favorable ou pas à cette ponction ah non
non non ben non moi je suis pas
favorable à la ponction moi je suis
rapporteur pour la branche vieillesse
mais auparavant j'étais aussi rapporteur
sur la branche accident de travail
maladie professionnelle tous les ans on
fonctionne aussi 1 milliard 1 milliard 2
1 milliard 4 sur sur cette branche donc
là encore c'est la même réponse que pour
les franchises c'est-à-dire que on
cherche de l'argent partout et en fait
les les retraites sont pas équilibrées
et quand quand on regarde la trajectoire
on aura encore des des soucis dans 2 3
ans ça ça commence en fait à augmenter
au niveau des déficits donc donc non je
pense que il y a peut-être à regarder
l'organisation du système de de santé
globalement et et à faire des des
économies là où il faut il faut faire
attention parce que l'hôpital va mal la
ville va va mal la médecine de ville
donc il faut faire très attention à ça
alors avant le budget de la Sécurité
sociale il y a un texte qui va être
examiné par les sénateurs et pas des
moindes c'est le projet de VO
immigration qui promet des débats agités
hier Gérald ran a dit qu'il tenait à
l'article 3 sur la régularisation des
métiers en tension mais qu'il voulait un
compromis avec les républicains alors
que c'est votre ligne rouge il est
possible ce compromis
euh pas vraiment je dirais pas vraiment
à à ce à ce stade euh au niveau de la
Commission on en fait ils ont renvoyé le
débat dans dans l'hémicycle il y a pas
eu de de de position à afficher parce
que le les centristes sont pas forcément
sur sur la même ligne que nous l'article
3 il ouvre la la porte finalement un
appel d'air pour pour les les migrants
et puis aussi le gouvernement depuis
quand même un certain moment a décidé de
s'attaquer à la fraude et c'est la
fraude la fraude aussi par les
employeurs alors si si on commence à à
dire que parfois on peut laisser la
fraude et que on va la régularisé je
pense que c'est assez assez dangereux
donc sur le plan de duimigration ou
Géral larmanin il dit dans le même temps
que c'est le texte le plus ferme de ces
20 dernières années qu'il permet d'avoir
une PO politique migratoire plus
efficace et il dit j'espère que la
droite républicaine aura un peu de
conscience qu'est-ce que ah mais la
conscience ça fait longtemps qu'on en a
en fait on a présenté beaucoup beaucoup
de textes qui sont pas allés plus loin
parce que le gouvernement n'a jamais
voulu les prendre là cont tenu du du
niveau en fait de de l'immigration
aujourd'hui c'est ça devient un sujet
primordial donc il fallait qu'il nous
écoute aussi avant et je pense queon n
serait pas dans cette situation dans
notre baromètre mensuel au doxa qui est
ce mois-ci consacré à à la loi
immigration 55 % des Français approuvent
la l'article 3 et la régularisation des
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
est-ce que du coup vous n'êtes pas en
décalage en dansçant ligne rouge euh bah
non je pense pas hein de toute façon
après tout dépend aussi comment on pose
les les les questions et d'expliquer sur
les métiers en tension on a on n'est pas
au plein emploi moi j'étais rapporteur
sur le texte plein emploi on n'est pas
on en est pas là on a aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup de personnes qui qui sont issus
de d'une immigration euh je dirais
récente et qui sont au chômage plus de
je crois plus de 15 % donc donc c'est là
en fait où il faut travailler la
situation et je pense que le texte plein
emploi normalement il devrait répondre
justement au métiers en tension un mot
sur un un autre sujet c'est l'IVG
puisque dimanche Emmanuel Macron a dit
que qu'il présenterait un texte d'ici la
fin de l'année pour que l'IVG soit
inscrite dans la Constitution en
reprenant la formule du Sénat sur la
liberté d'y recourir vous vrez ce texte
alors moi je'y suis pas favorable du
tout parce que en fait dans la
Constitution je veux dire pourquoi on
met pas le droit au logement et puis
plein d'autres droits donc on commence à
ouvrir une une porte et ça va devenir
très compliqué sur sur l'avortement et
sur l'IVG bien entendu enfin moi je suis
une femme hein donc je vais pas dire que
je je suis compte mais l'inscrire dans
la Constitution je vois pas du tout en
fait comment ça va la protéger moi jeis
donner un exemple Monsieur Mélenchon il
a fait toute sa campagne en disant que
il enlèverait la Constitution il ferait
une constituante donc le marbre ça
n'existe pas donc donc voilà n'importe
n'importe quel gouvernement s'il a une
une majorité parce que ça il faut une
majorité très large pour aller au
Congrès pourra y revenir donc donc voilà
donc vous ne voterez pas ce texte vous
ne voterez pas cette proposition ce
projet de loi constitutionnel pardon on
va parler de votre texte cette fois
cette proposition de loi qui a été votée
cette nuit largement au qui vise à
protéger la langue française des dérives
de l'incriture de l'écriture inclusive
c'est l'intitulé de vot texte texte
contesté par la gauche on va le voir on
va voir les temps forts de cette séance
avec Alex
[Musique]
Poussard bonjour Alex bonjour ran
bonjour Pascal grenier et Alex le Sénat
donc adopté 7ette nu la proposition de
loi de Pascal grunny pour renforcer
l'interdiction de l'écriture inclusive
alors d'abord appelez-nous c'est quoi
l'écriture inclusive ah oui on va
d'abord rappeler ce que c'est pour nos
téléspectateurs alors l'écriture
inclusive est définie par ses partisans
comme une écriture qui fait progresser
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
alors il y a plusieurs formes d'écriture
inclusive par exemple au lieu de dire
l'homme avec un grand H l'homme en
général et bien on pourrait parler du
genre humain ça c'est un type d'écriture
inclusive autre exemple pour certains
métiers on peut employer une forme
féminine qui sonne féminin à l'oreille
et qui n'est pas actuellement dans les
usages par exemple pour dire docteur on
peut dire doctor et puis il y a une
écriture inclusive qui change
complètement la typographie de la langue
française et c'est cette écriture qui
est très critiquée actuellement pour
parler par exemple des nouveaux
sénateurs élus en septembre et bien on
écrira les nouveaux sénateurs avec cette
écriture qui s'affiche à votre écran et
donc avec différents terminaisons séparé
par des points médians alors pour des
raisons de clarté l'écriture inclusive
est déjà interdite à l'école et dans le
Journal officiel et cette proposition de
loi va plus loin dans l'interdiction et
oui ce texte interdit tout simplement
l'écriture inclusive dans tous les
documents dont le droit impose qu'il
soit rédigé en français c'est-à-dire les
documents administratifs commerciaux les
contrats de travail les actes juridiques
et durant l'examen du texte en
commission et bien les sénateurs ont
même précisé l'interdiction en prohibant
notamment l'emploi de ce qu'on appelle
les pronoms personnels neutres inclusifs
c'est-à-dire yel al Hul alors ce sujet
et bien il a donné hier soir un débat
très tranché avec d'un côté la droite et
le centre qui sont contre et de l'autre
les socialistes écologistes ont essayé
de défendre tant bien que mal les
bienfaits de l'écriture inclusive on va
écouter la signénatrice socialiste
Laurence
Rossignol Croy moi qu' a des enquêtes et
sérieuses déjà à 5 ou 6 ans considèreent
qu'elles n'ont pas les mêmes compétences
que les garçons déjà elles pensent
qu'elles sont moins doué pour les
mathématiques et pour les sciences c'est
l'ensemble des représentations et tout
le travail qu'on fait consiste à enlever
de la tête des petites filles cette idée
qu'elle serait moins performante que les
garçons mais faut reconnaître que
pendant toute une scolarité quand on
quand on entend en grammaire le masculin
l'emporte sur le féminin faut que les
enseignants soient furieusement outillés
pour expliquer aux enfants alors ça on
dit ça pour la grand-mère mais pour tout
le reste de la société ça marche pas
comme ça tout le monde est
égal hier soir la droite a estimé que
l'écriture inclusive venait du mouvement
W un mouvement venu d'Amérique du Nord
et qui viserait à déconstruire notre
société on va écouter le sénateur
Étienne blanc l'écriture inclusive
trouve ses racin dans une politique plus
générale de reconnaissance de la
primauté des identités c'est une
idéologie
mortifère imposé des campus américains
ou de ceux de l'Europe du Nord sous
prétexte d'égalité des sexes elle vise à
détruire le français en s'inscrivant
dans une culture
voque une culture qui vise plus
largement à contester notre modèle de
civilisation voilà des positions très
tranché alors au final les deux camps
n'ont pas réussi à se mettre d'accord la
proposition de loi a été adoptée et du
côté du gouvernement alors même si
Emmanuel Macron s'est prononcé hier très
clairement contre l'écriture inclusive
et bien la ministre de la Culture Rima
abdoumak n'a pas pris position dans ce
débat et a estimé je cite que le rôle de
l'État et du Parlement n'était pas
d'être dans une police de la langue et
Alex vous restez avec nous évidemment on
va revenir sur Emmanuel Macron mais sur
ce qui s'est passé hier au au Sénat la
gauche Alex l'a rappelé a vertement
critiqué votre texte texte rétrograde
réactionnaire qui s'inscrit dans un
courant conservateur qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça ah ben moi je me sens pas
du tout rétrograde d'ailleurs je vous
donner un exemple hier j'ai une collègue
socialiste qui a dit qu' sétait
interrogé pour le le le nom de
laquesteur alors je sais pas ce qu'ils
ont d'ailleurs choisi mais en tout cas
moi je peux vous dire que c'était dans
ma délégation de vice-président c'est
que c'est moi qui est fléché au moins
une femme sur les trois questurs donc je
ne crois pas que je suis rétrograde mais
en revanche les combats ils sont son pas
dans l'écriture le l'égalité homme-femme
certainement pas quand quand il parle du
masculin l'emporte sur le féminin moi
j'aié étaé aussi une petite fille
j'étais j'aimais beaucoup l'orthographe
et la gramère j'ai jamais entendu les
garçons sont plus forts que les filles
moi c une règle de grammaire point et ça
reste aujourd'hui donc donc franchement
le le combat rétrograde je pense qu'il
est plutôt chez eux je pense qu'il faut
qu' qu'il se se batte plutôt sur
l'égalité homme-femme qui n'est pas
encore complète sur les rémunérations
n'est pas encore allé au bout et donc
vous ne pensez pas que quand même cette
phrase qu'on inculque aux enfants très
petits le masculin l'emporte sur le
féminin vous ne pensez pas que ça
intègre les esprits non pas du tout
franchement pas du tout moi je connais
personne qui qui a réagi comme ça enfin
vous aussi vous avez été petit je crois
pas que non mais tout le monde se
souvient de cette phrase quand même bah
bien sûr parce que dans les règles de
grammaire d'ailleurs je pense que ça
s'oublie un peu avec la jeune génération
qui fait beaucoup de fautes donc ce
serait bien effectivement que cette
règle soit soit remise mise au boutt du
jour non sincèrement hier on a eu
effectivement un cvage gauche droite
mais on n pas eu d'arguments forts sur
sur sur cette écriture à être favorable
à cette à cette écriture et je crois
sincèrement que au contraire cette
écriture qui ne se parle pas vient
vraiment perturber l'apprentissage de la
langue pour tous nos jeunes Français qui
ont des difficultés aujourd'hui et et
ils sont jeunes aujourd'hui demain ils
ils sont dans le monde du travail et moi
dans dans le cadre du texte plein emploi
je peux vous dire que les personnes les
plus éloignées de l'emploi sont déjà
celles qui maîtrise pas du tout la
langue donc pour vous cette écriture
inclusive c'est une aspiration de
quelques militants ou c'est une
aspiration de la société car de plus en
plus de personnes sont séduites par
cette écriture inclusive ah oui à Paris
certainement mais chez moi pas du tout
en revanche moi je su je suis d'accord
avec vous que certains utiliseent
l'écriture inclusive mais ils s'en
rendent même pas compte ou alors ils
donnent des documents qui ont été
préparé par des des secrétaires et
cetera qui utilisent cette écriture là
et personne chez moi parce que moi je
interrogé notamment pour pour les
personnes qui avaient des documents
écrits en écriture inclusive ils m'ont
dit mais de quoi tu nous parles voilà
donc à Paris ça fait débat ça fait
Desbat dans dans l'hémicycle mais
sincèrement chez moi mais en quoi en
quoi c'est un danger pour la langue
française cette écriture inclusive mais
parce que déjà ça ne se parle pas donc
déjà vous avez une écriture qui est
différente en en fait de de la langue
orale donc donc voilà et le le le danger
c'est vraiment la difficulté pour les
personnes je crois que elle exclut en
fait tout tous les 10 hein dyslexiques
notamment toutes les personnes aussi qui
sont aveugles malvoyantes et donc qui
utilisent des logiciels qui ne
reconnaissent pas cette écriture
inclusive et vous avez vu ce que vous
avez mis comme phrase avec le point x et
cetera c'est incompréhensible
incompréhensible et c'est pas comme ça
qu'on aura l'égalité homme-femme ni
l'égalité entre les les genres qu'il
faut pas du tout je veux dire ignorer
mais qu'on peut aider autrement et là
c'est encore du communautarisme il faut
faire attention la langue c'est notre
bien commun c'est ce qui nous
caractérise et c'est
aussi à penser la langue française dans
le monde la francophonie on a un recul
quand même sur sur la langue française
donc ça c'est important alors justement
hier Emmanuel on était chez vous dans
l'aine à Viller Cotteret pour inaugurer
la Cité internationale de la langue
française on va revenir sur cette cité
mais dans son discours il a fustigé
l'écriture inclusive on l'écoute c'est
pour cela aussi qu'il faut permettre à
cette langue de vivre de s'inspirer des
autres de voler des mots y compris à
l'autre bout du monde j'y reviendrai
tout à l'heure de continuer à
inventer mais d'en garder aussi les
fondements les Socl de sa grandmère la
force de sa syntaxe et de ne pas céder
aux air du temps dans cette langue le
masculin fait le neutre on n' pas besoin
d'y rajouter des points au milieu des
mots ou des tirés ou des choses pour la
rendre
visible vous avez assisté à ce discours
he vous y étiez Pascal grunny ça vous a
étonné de la part du chef de l'État vous
attendiez à une telle phrase le jour de
l'examen de votre texte euh en fait ça
m'a pas étonné parce que j'avais décidé
de de lui dire au moment où en fait où
il nous a salué et donc il m'a bien dit
qu' il est qu'il était absolument pas
favorable voir contre vraiment cette
écriture
inclusive il é applaudi aussi vous
saviez qu'il allait dire ça je non non
non ah non je le savais pas je pensais
pas qu'il irait jusque là moi je lui ai
posé la question voilà en arrivant pour
que j'ai un soutien pour que le texte
progresse ensuite à l'Assemblée
nationale et justement justement est-ce
que vous avez des informations des
garanties sur l'avenir de votre texte à
l'Assemblée est-ce que la majorité
présidentielle à l'Assemblée pourrait le
voter je je pense je pense que je pense
que oui après hier la ministre qui était
sur le en même temps hein voilà on se
pose la question le président de la
République je pense qu'il était clair
donc pas pas encore de position claire
sur l'avenir du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale ben bon d'abord j'ai aussi mes
collègues députés LR sur qui je je
compte aussi mais pour l'instant
effectivement on n pas pas d'assurance
mais juste pourquoi parce que le le
rassemblement national a déposé un texte
il y a quelques jours pour interdire
l'écriture inclusive pourquoi les
républicains ne ne l'ont pas soutenu du
coup alors je je sais qu'en commission
ils l'ont soutenu et après il n'était
pas présent au moment du du débat alors
peut-être parce que ils étaient par
ailleurs hein ça je je ne sais pas euh
donc vous regrettez que ce ce texte
n'est pas pu aller au bout à l'Assemblée
nationale bon moi je regrette pas parce
que c'est le RN mais mais en revanche
c'est c'est vrai quand même que le sujet
il est au-delà de la politique il est
quand même vis-àis en fait des enfants
et de la population qui qui est en
difficulté par rapport à la à la langue
ouais alors justement au-delà de la
langue française on a entendu des des
arguments hier dans dans l'hémicycle sur
le fait que l'écriture inclusive était
un un vecteur de déconstruction pour ne
pas dire de décivilisation c'est le mot
qu'avait employé Emmanuel Macron vous
êtes d'accord avec ça euh oui oui bien
sûr bien sûr parce que ça derrière c'est
le wisme donc moi je je vais dire que on
en a assez d'aller chercher aux
États-Unis ou bah il fait pas mieux
vivre là-bas de de ramener ici toute
toutes ces idéologies qui qui en plus
font vraiment partie de communauté voilà
et on l'a bien vu hier en fait donc ça
fait pas du tout avancer la France on a
la même chose avec la question que je
m'avais posée avant sur l'IVG en fait
c'est parce qu'aux États-Unis il y a eu
des États qui qui ont justement modifié
le leur loi et et c'est revenu chez nous
alors que c'est pas du tout le le débat
l'IVG il y a aucun groupe politique
aujourd'hui qui qui l'a fait donc c'est
la même chose sur le wisme c'est la même
chose sur l'écriture inclusive restons
en France et avec notre langue française
nous devons être très fierers on a
entendu Emmanuel Macron vous le dites on
a Mo entendu la ministre de la Culture
vous êtes déçu parim abdoumak euh oui
oui oui oui j'étais très déçu hier soir
quand je l'ai je l'ai entendu parce que
je je savais qu'elle avait cette
position puisque que le comment elle
avait été auditionnée aussi par Cédric
Vial du texte voilà mais je pensais
qu'avec ce que le président avait avait
dit le matin elle aurait changé d'avis
et en fait non elle ne l'a elle n'a pas
changé donc vous es un dernier
finalement ce qu'elle dit la ministre de
la Culture c'est c'est une chose d'être
opposé à l'écriture inclusive mais c'est
une autre de vouloir légiférer pour
réglementer l'orthographe française
est-ce que pour reprendre ces terme on
n'est pas en train de faire une police
de la langue c'est la c'est pas la
première fois on a la loi tout bon aussi
en fait et et là c'est c'est un combat
justement qu' contre tous les
anglicismes donc c'est pas la première
fois je pense que là cette écriture
inclusive elle elle progresse très vite
et elle modifie en fait notre langue
sans y apporter quelque chose de positif
la la notre langue elle est vivante et
bien entendu on le voit chaque année des
nouveaux mots l'Académie française elle
se prononce sur sur nouveau vocabulaire
là ça change aussi finalement la
grand-mère merci Alex à tout à l'heure
on verra ce que pense les Français du
projet de loi immigration ce sera à
suivre dans le club on va continuer à
parler de cette site international de la
langue française on va aller voir
puisqueévidemment ça fait l'actualité
dans l'ancienne Picardie où on retrouve
Jean-Marc chevaucher bonjour Jean-Marc
merci d'être avec nous rédacteur en chef
adjoint au Courrier Picard et Jean-Marc
vous avez bien sûr suivi ce ce
déplacement des Emmanuel Macron et cette
inauguration de la cité de la langue
française
oui Orian alors on s'est intéressé
évidemment à à l'histoire on a relevé
comme tout le monde que cette première
police de la langue pour reprendre les
termes utilisit tout à l'heure sur sur
le plateau a été édicté en 1539 donc ça
fait 5 siècles quasiment l'ordonnance
qui a rendu obligatoire le français
c'est la première fois que on sit euh
autorisé à à légiférer hein puisque
autrefois c'était la langue régionale
qui l'emportait un peu partout et puis
on a investi 210 millions d'euros dans
la la rénovation du du château de Viller
côré la restauration du château qui
était dans un état un petit peu
pitoyable avant que qu'Emmanuel Macron
en mars
2017 ne décide d' d'en d'en faire le
centre de la la langue française c'est
un petit peu le le dossier d'Emmanuel
Macron de de du premier quinquena et
puis c'est un petit peu sa réalisation
comme comme la pyramide du Louvre ou le
musée du kbranli voyez sauf que là cette
fois c'est en province et puis que ça a
un petit côté monarque qu'on
retrouve une critique qu'on fait souvent
au président puisque c'est ça représente
le le choix de François prier alors le
prix que ça a coûté c'est 210 millions
d'euros investis voilà est-ce est-ce que
de votre côté madame gruni que je salue
à qui je dis bonjour puisque je ne l'ai
pas fait au début de mon intervention
est-ce que pour vous ces 210 millions
d'euros qui qui rénov le le château ben
c'est la preuve qu'on peut trouver de
l'argent qu'on pourrait peut-être aussi
rénover toutes les églises fortifiées de
tierche qui sont dans un état pas
toujours
excellent bonjour monsieur
chevaucher ben c'est vrai que c'est
c'est c'est un sujet c'est églises
d'ailleurs le président Emmanuel Macron
a dit qu'il allait essayer
d'accompagner des avec des subventions
la restauration des des églises parce
que c'est partout il y a des églises des
chapelles on a un patrimoine
extraordinaire en revanche comme vous le
dites il y a pas beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent bon là moi je vais vous dire je
suis très fière que ce soit chez nous en
Picardie ça existe toujours la Picardie
n'est-ce pas monsieur chevaucher dans
les Haut- de France particulièrement
dans le département de l'INE ce château
là était complètement à l'abandon il
allait vraiment je pense un jour
disparaître et et pour nous le tourisme
c'est c'est toujours un sujet de faire
venir les les personnes chez nous les
les tous les Français de de venir
visiter notre département et puis bien
entendu ensuite nos nos département
voisin alors justement madame madame
Gruny au-delà du prix que que ça a coûté
et de l'argent qu'on trouve quand le
président l'a décidé est-ce que vous
pensez que ce ce château vous étiez en
train de le dire va véritablement être
une chance pour pour le département
au-delà pour la pour la région si si
tout le monde se met autour de la table
je dirais parce que il y a il y a des
des des des des personnalités politique
très différentes aussi aussi bien à
Viller côteré qui est dirigé par un
maire Front national que que dans la
région qui est dirigée par Xavier
Bertrand ou ou dans le département
est-ce que est-ce que c'est une chance
pour le département et au-delà pour pour
la région et ça vous allez me dire oui
je pense donc comment faire pour que ça
devienne vrai véritablement un enjeu
régional et bien moi je pense que il
faut absolument l'intégrer dans tous nos
programmes de de tourisme et mon
collègue du du département en parlait
hier justement de le de le mettre dans
nos programmes et sincèrement c'est à
nous en faire aussi la publicité moi
j'ai trouvé que c'était magnifique moi
j'invite tout le monde à venir c'est
vraiment c'est pas un musée c'est
vraiment quelque chose de vivant
exposition permanente elle est très
vivante ludique donc donc c'est à nous
en fait à en faire la la promotion et
pour une fois vous l'avez dit qu'on a un
projet présidentiel qui est hors Paris
je pense que il faut vraiment mettre
mettre ça sous sous le feu de de de la
rampe Viller côterè c'est aussi un
endroit qui est touché par la
désindustrialisation par le chômage qui
est dirigé désormais par le
rassemblement national l'Élysée veut
aussi en faire un moyen de lutter contre
le RN en ramenant de l'emploi en
ramenant du tourisme est-ce que pour
vous c'est comme ça qu'on lutte contre
le RN ah ben bien sûr parce que le le RN
chez nous vous savez on a plus de
communiste pour pour ainsi dire donc
c'est c'est les les les personnes chez
nous se se tourne vers vers le
rassemblement national qui effectivement
CR avec les loups est d'accord avec ce
que disent les gens mais n'apporte
jamais de solution donc oui bien sûr
l'emploi mais chez nous justement ça
passe aussi par un meilleur enseignement
un meilleur accompagnement des personnes
parce qu'on est malheureusement le
premier département pour l'ilectrisme
donc moi c'est vraiment pour ça que je
je combats cette cette écriture donc la
cité c'est une belle réponse justement
et pour entrer
tout toutes les personnes pas seulement
les axonnés mais les picards et et tous
les personnes habitant les Haut- de
France à justement à on faire je dirais
notre projet à nous pas que présidentiel
et on regarde la une du Courrier Picard
justement Jean-Marc ouis juste Jean-Marc
pardon one la une du Courrier Picard
parce que c'est fini contrôle technique
les motards Picards n'en veulent pas
c'est à la une du Courrier Picard merci
beaucoup Jean-Marc chevaucher d'avoir
été avec nous Pascal Grun on reparlera
de l'inauguration de cette cité puisque
notre journaliste Mathias SZ était hier
à viel côteret pour la suivre on verra
son reportage jeudi dans cette émission
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure merci
à vous